My blood and stomach be from Hashimoto or something else and should a probiotic help.
Well probiotic isn't going to help Hashimoto. So if you have Hashimoto's you also have to
make sure absolutely positively that you are gluten free. So gluten is a molecular mimic
cross-reactant to thyroid dominant. So you cannot eat gluten. So again, go to the autoine course,
I have an entire module on Hashimoto's. So make sure you look up there, you haven't. But if you're
eating gluten, dairy can be a cross-reactant to gluten. You're eating gluten in dairy with Hashimoto.
If you do anything's game, I mean, that could be it. Also consider doing a Syrex 10. If you have
bloating, if you're not taking, if you're already taking HCL with digestive enzymes,
consider upping that for a period of time. If doing a Syrex 10 is out of the
financial consideration. So all those things to think about with Hashimoto's.
Hashimoto's in itself is not going to cause bloating. But comorbidities that go along with Hashimoto's
which are food sensitivities, gluten definitely cross-reactant inflammation,
creating antibodies to gluten in dairy are all causes of bloating and grain fog, grain inflammation.
So be careful of all of those things. Getting tested for cross-reactant foods might be something
you want to look at too. So if a person is like, I have Hashimoto's and I would gluten free in dairy
for years and I'm still having these issues, well, you could have other issues with other foods.
So anything, so you have autoimmune, what do you have antibodies to your self tissue? Anything that's
going to cause inflammation, it's going to cause your immune system to get worse. That's the problem
when you have cancer. So you have cancer, you have to be stimulating your immune system to kill
the cancer. But every time you're stimulating your immune system, you're affecting your autoimmunity.
So it's a catch-22, but it's like, okay, well, I'm going to deal with these symptoms of Hashimoto's
and kill my cancer or am I going to, you know, let's succumb the cancer and have less Hashimoto symptoms.
So, let's you have to play with that balance.